welcome to podcast greetings from
podcast Ville the Church of what's
happened now is brought to you by zip
recruiter hiring used to be hard
multiple job site stacks of resumes a
confusion Rubin process but today hiring
is easy and you can only have it one
place that gets it done right and that
zip recruiter comm slash Church right
now
zip recruit is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day and right now today try
zip recruiter for free Eugene what I
just said free my listeners can go to
zip record calm slash Church see Hur CH
that zip recruited calm slash Church
right now zipper cooler the smartest way
to hire let's kick this [ __ ]
meal any Bravo's in the house today
what's happenin dough [ __ ] where's the
music no more music we had to collect
the [ __ ] me really yeah you got
busted
we got warning ah we got red-flagged
that sucks they sent the [ __ ] feds
and let people [ __ ] sleep on the
goddamn sidewalk sidewalk but you can't
[ __ ] play little clips of music to
help the bad trust me you don't
understand you don't understand that
it's taking a piece out of me because
that was part of the thing giving them
[ __ ] that I even forgot about yeah it
was through my journeys that I even
forgot about I love like right now you
know what I'm missing Tom Morello on
Sirius that's the best show on Sirius
right now what is he talking about he
talks about that style of music Tom
Morello show on Sirius XM music show oh
my god he had his [ __ ] mother on the
other day 93 years old and he goes tell
him the story mom about their first
performance ever at Lollapalooza in
1992-93
and they go out the night before you
know she used to bring him up on stage
huh 62 year old retired schoolteacher
are you ready for the world's greatest
[ __ ] rock'n'roll band Rage
Against the Machine that's her oh so now
she's 93 and she's like you know [ __ ]
three days from dying but she's still
sharp man she's like eat your vegetables
you know and he's like ma ma relax look
that's all about the story she told the
story about what they went to Louisiana
and New Orleans got arrested and they
had to go to the Lollapalooza and wait
for them to get out of jail and she
wanna upon stage and they started [ __ ]
the New Orleans police she led the cheer
did I ever tell you my story how I met
Tom around I remember one day you i sat
with you and had lunch with him at the
old place where he used to hang out this
had to be 20 years ago but the first
time Fairfax where was where was the
place that mean you saw him with Brogan
and we had a burrito with him right next
to the coffee bean on Fairfax in Sunset
that's coffee bean and there's that they
used to be a taco place next to it oh my
god Baja Fresh you mean every [ __ ]
day yeah so one day we went you me and
Joe and Tom Morello was sitting there by
himself like this is my operation
yeah gentlemen yeah and his Tom Morello
from the hottest band now this had to be
99 mm yeah and you sat down like like I
went out I had to get something I met
him before you had met him before right
yeah though this is the craziest story
right so you know I've always been a big
Browns fan right big Cleveland Browns
fan when I was 8 my brother was 12 his
job was to humiliate me he had a big
baseball card collection I was jealous
of the baby baseball baseball card
collection so he looked at one of his
cards and he gave to me because here you
could have this one it was the Cleveland
Indians back when they were a joke 30
games behind first place every day and
it was Dennis Eckersley rookie card any
game of that car and I'm eight and I'm
like okay I love everything about
Cleveland from this
so that's how I got him to Cleveland
Cleveland Indians Cleveland Cavaliers
Cleveland Browns since I was [ __ ] 8
dude 8 and 10 right Brian Sipe Dave
Logan oh the whole the whole era and
then the fumbling and the driver is
buying her Bernie Kosar
Webster slaughter all that [ __ ] so then
the Browns move and they move when then
we used to beat him up exactly the drive
in the phone.i yeah yeah they'd kill it
they killed us but anyways in 96 and 96
Fame Bart Motel took the team and moved
to [ __ ] Baltimore they became the
Baltimore [ __ ] Ravens and now
Cleveland all of us on the Cleveland
[ __ ] Browns were gone clearly doesn't
have a football team no more so
everybody's pissed I'm pissed
everyone's pissed like [ __ ] the
Baltimore Ravens they start blowing up
the Baltimore Ravens and the Cleveland
Browns eventually came back but three
years later so that first year Cleveland
Browns fans don't know what the [ __ ] did
who became a Cleveland ooh what team the
Cleveland Browns moved to Baltimore and
became the Baltimore Ravens 10 Colts
left after the Colts up the Colts
already went to Indianapolis but the
browns became the Baltimore Ravens in
1996 that was Ray Lewis as a rookie year
and that's that's that's what they
picked in the first round but anyways
the Browns that have a team so you know
here comes you know the off the off
season they're talking about the Ravens
they start showing off the colors and
everybody's like for everybody from
Cleveland [ __ ] the Ravens [ __ ] the
Ravens and I wasn't all about [ __ ]
the bravin's too but as the season
approached I thought you know I really
check out welcome preseason game and it
was New York Giants versus Baltimore
Ravens and the only place that was
showing it was at that Promenade in
Santa Monica there was a place called
Yankee doodles I don't even know if it's
still there but it's gigantic sports bar
two levels two level sports were huge
it's like Dave & Buster's with two
levels and they have downstairs the
government [ __ ] 50 TVs everywhere and
then upstairs so Sunday's it's just a
[ __ ] football extravaganza there and
so I went and the first you know there's
Browns fans all over the country because
the Browns have like it's
they've been around since like 40s or
50s or something like that so there's
fans everywhere they moved I only moves
so there's brown
backers everywhere but it was the Ravens
first year they had no backers anywhere
they had no outside fans outside of
Baltimore I was but I wanted to see the
game anyway so I saw New York Giants
versus Baltimore Ravens and I became a
Ravens fan just by watching up cuz I
thought that Vinny Testaverde Mike these
are the same guys Leroy hoard but these
guys are purple they're like the purple
Browns I'm like [ __ ] I'm not gonna
let Art Modell take football away from
me I'm not gonna let him destroy my
Sundays so I just became a Baltimore
Ravens fan instantly so I would show up
there every Sunday and out they put me I
was the only Ravens fan outside of
Baltimore so they put me downstairs
there's nobody there in the [ __ ]
corner I'm watching I'm at the
everyone's upstairs going nuts and they
got me in a corner with the Baltimore
Ravens game right and then the Baltimore
Ravens played the Rams st. Louis Rams
and so I'm sitting there he's 1996 and
I'm sitting there and there's a there's
a Rams fan next to me watching and it's
[ __ ] tom morello but I had no idea I
had no idea what's him I personally
didn't have any Rage Against the Machine
Records I wasn't really a big Rage
Against the Machine fan I like that you
know [ __ ] you if you do it Janome that
was all cool and everything but for me I
was actually doing rap rock too but I
was Rage Against the Machine was more
like Led Zeppelin doing rap and my style
was more Nine Inch Nails doing rap so
you know I wasn't I wasn't that into
rage against me I'm just being honest so
I really didn't recognize you know what
I mean and while watching the game and
at halftime we just start talking you
know just bullshitting and he asked me
was what do you do I got you know I'm
out here in Hollywood trying to make it
in music now there's a strip club DJ at
the party and I did get a strip club but
trying to make it music you know so
really this what kind of band you like I
got I told him it's like Rage Against
the Machine except you know how they're
like Led Zeppelin II I go we're not like
that were more Nine Inch Nails II he's
like oh really
here we go so you know that's my band I
said why what do you mean cuz I'm the
guitar player for Rage Against mashenka
[ __ ] yeah because yeah it was me you
know then he proved it obviously and
then there's a trip you know cuz he's a
big Rams fan he's even to this day the
Giants were giant Rams fan so for you
know the rest of the game were just I
was just like put a Bigfoot my mother
that was like sort of like talking [ __ ]
on blowing up my band and kind of bring
in Rage Against the Machine down a
little bit but anyways that's and then I
ran into him a few other times like you
said like maybe four or five other times
I'd run into him somewhere like hey the
the Ravens fan remember he goes oh [ __ ]
that's right Yankee doodles 96 so ups
but that's it he probably don't remember
me no more it's it's great no way I saw
I saw people and they went away like I
go through that place like when it got
to the Comedy Store it was Tommy Lee
Tommy Lee would come down Wednesdays
Thursdays get a drink at the different
bar dr. chewy
I never said two words though it was
nice to see Tommy Lee and if it wasn't
Tommy Lee it was a crazy guitar player
from poison he's crazy
oh he was drinking [ __ ] he's crazy
I was he developed c.c. deville I would
see him
who else did I see a lot that slash I
would see slash like one night would
don't comedy at the Union and slash was
dead then I went to Burbank Airport
slash is dead yeah slash their necks
that what the I had a walk through
Convention and slash was dead you know
it was like and then I never saw slash
again ever again
yeah it's like so weird out and now I
don't even know I was like extend the
neck I could be standing next to [ __ ]
Nick Jonas and I don't know exactly I
don't know who the [ __ ] they are yeah
you had Rikki Rockett on your podcast
right yeah he's an old friend of mine
yes he used to hang out for a while
back up cuz he he did you Jitsu at John
jocks as well
and we became friends and back in 97
we had a plan to put together and then a
magazine before I was even called MMA it
was called no-holds-barred for a while
and we're gonna put out a magazine come
no-holds-barred he was gonna finance it
and I was gonna be like the editor or
whatever right that was the plan so we
thought [ __ ] if we're gonna do this
gonna be awesome we got to start going
to UFC s and this is back in 97 when the
UFC's are like underground you know the
first you have first two you have C's
first four or five actually huge and
then they they lost their cable contract
and they went underground and you could
only see it on satellite and plant you
know so there was just one UFC coming up
in Kemper Louisiana it was like maybe
3,000 people capacity Joe that's when
Joe was backstage report hilarious so we
went to that you know to report on it
and and interview fighters and stuff the
magazine never came out kind of you know
just flaked on it did you know joke a
Java barely I knew he was uh he trained
at John Jaques but I had never run into
him and I was and Ricky's like yeah that
dude he he's on Newsradio and he trains
the John jocks I'm like oh yeah I heard
about him I haven't run into I'm like
and we actually talked they're like hey
dude you train at
jean-jacques and he said yeah so we
that's what we kind of first sort of
like Retton like met like and then you
know a couple years later he started
taking the classes that I was in and
then you know we just from that point
and that was great he has evolved
because I came in around that time yes I
met you like in 2000-2001 know was it
yeah I've been here since 97 started
[ __ ] around with Joe like 98 I met
you like 99 and a half as far as I
remember we met at the comedy story yes
because no Sunday night yeah that was
back at in there in 2000 that's when you
trained with him that's all I know you
want to teach you that yeah now you
trend but I was a purple belt and he was
a blue guys it was a reasonably be
around you two together
we would just talk about sweeps and [ __ ]
and I didn't know what the [ __ ] I
thought he was talking about the old
school sweeps yeah I can New York to
kung-fu sweeps where I tried to kick
your leg out for Monday yeah it's been
another stillage it then legit but
nobody I always say that that that I
don't even know that wood used to be
those things when the seventies when I
was growing up you swept off a spinning
back-kick
like you did the spinning back-kick
twice and you went to [ __ ] get that
guy at competitions remember I used to
go to competitions where you couldn't
kick the face yeah but you could kick
from the here it was called semi contact
yeah if you kicked touch the face you
got disqualified yeah
so I always aim that heel for the
midsection but I would set them up and
if I if I knew that they were coming at
me if they're like if they were right
hand or righties I would take that left
leg that's how I used to win those
competitions is when I was like 10 I
just figured out that sweeping was the
way to go and I became a sweeper in
those competitions some from 10 to 14 I
used to just sweep people that was my
[ __ ] if I caught your leg I would
just sweep you and then I trained with
people would just sweat people this was
way like basic karate yeah there was
nobody tying a neighborhood none of that
[ __ ] there was no jujitsu there was
nothing it was Aikido Richard Bohannon
aikido school on 68th Street and
everything else was karate with the
fists Hassan's father yeah some crazies
that was my first karate teacher was a
son's father but I didn't go to
competitions with our sons father
I didn't start going to competitions
till I moved to New Jersey and I started
training with this Vietnam vet who was
[ __ ] nuts why did you move to New
Jersey because my mother had the bar in
that neighborhood hmm
so at that time in that part of New
Jersey the big schools the food job I go
fool who by the way I'm still there on
the second floor above a Carvel
what's a car Val ice-cream store oh okay
and then the other big school was
gushing roux karate it was like that was
it
so you either and it was like a game I
think being part of the gang then like
if we saw you in the mall is [ __ ] [ __ ]
food job pie in the house you know and
then we were like some of us would know
each other for pretty much meaning let's
plan it over there watch out I see Emily
come over you control the virus you
don't at that age you really did you
took it that personal you know and they
made the Karate Kid
muhuali they that's how those people
treated people you're a part of a gang
now you idiots hung out together in
school you know you're the Karate Kid
[ __ ] until you want to put it to a black
school and you got lit up and then there
was no more karate kids yeah that was
the end of it he wept like some Beach
and he picked on some skinny black dude
he just lit off for you up and that
would be the end and we take one bTW I
forget who I was with we got a beat I
used to when I was a kid there was a
time when I lived in New York City and I
was just calling in I lived in New York
City but I would go to Union City with
my mother so I had to find something to
do so I joined the karate school while
she was at that at her bar that would
get me out of there for an hour let me
walk yeah and I became friends with a
couple of karate kids and that was the
first time at night that I would tell
her like that Savin my gotta go and I
would take Mikey and me and these creepy
kids I hung out with two creepy kid
karate sets my first one was his kid he
had to be don't Lenny something he was a
pervert where he didn't work completed
work up the balls to pervert eyes yeah
like the you know Messiah had he hung
out with this dude named Pina who was my
age and my family know his family we
called him like crazy Mike he lives with
his mother
he really like call her a [ __ ] [ __ ]
we were kids now me and Pino came from
the Cuban house this kid Mike was from a
white house the first time I heard him
call his mother a [ __ ] I almost had a
[ __ ] heart attack you understand me
like that was the first house I ever
seen that white like he had a brother
and a sister and they all abused the
mother and told the fathers shut up I
was like what the [ __ ] is going on but
it didn't matter everything they were
the Super's of a building and we would
go down to a basement at night and [ __ ]
each other to death maybe no crazy Mike
and there was somebody else Lobito
subito subito was the Super's kid so
that's how we got access to the building
so Pete though he was a Cuban kid with a
mustache and we would just [ __ ] each
other up but Mike was a man so when you
spotted Mike you got better so I tried
to spar with Mike every night we kicked
you know real light and stuff we would
go to hunt that we bought our own in
those days we had targets and you had to
hold them but it was like three inch pad
on a piece of wood and that's what we do
at night and then when I got older guy
that was a different quick clank along
with a Mario Diaz Mario Diaz for Chinese
Cuban he spelled his name with a he
instead of an a like I spelt it and his
father was like a Chinese doctor and
[ __ ] and then he would never be home
they would never hold the parents so
we'd all go home do homework and then
we'd had to Mario Diaz his house and the
family had money they had a nice
basement but that's what we went crazy
that's when we will any Bravo back crazy
we used to go to Chinatown and we would
buy iron palm technique we would hit a
bag every night we had the Cubs my hands
we would work the iron palm room hit
brakes with our [ __ ] hands that's
that's the Joey karate style right crazy
we prepay see crazy and we used to beat
each other up so much that his father
had like walls that were nice but we
started punching through the walls I
swear to god we
would be fighting and we just punch
through the walls there had to be three
holes every three feet from like me
trying to sidekick you and you get out
of the way and my foot will go to the
wall like that type of [ __ ] nobody ever
got caught but nobody ever got stitches
we got a lot of bruises and there was a
lot of broken noses in there dog I had a
broken nose they must have hit me 15
times with the broken I like that's why
I think I broke my nose one time I went
in there with a broken nose one time we
just we should just beat each other up
and they friendly
beat up yeah we were friendly not MMA
kicked you in the head type [ __ ] no no
no no if you kicked you only not to kick
the body we would always go for the
stomach from cakes that type of [ __ ] you
know I did karate for six months yeah
yeah yeah I got before I gotta I got a
green stripe on my wipeout
I took one test to get that stripe in my
on the results it's like a piece of
paper it said excellent overhand knife
strike so I thought that was my [ __ ] and
that was my [ __ ] so while I was doing
karate I was living in an apartment
building and above me was this huge
Russian dude or I don't know these yeah
I think it was usually the Russian or
polish and he [ __ ] hated me cuz I had
this girlfriend only girl ever that I've
ever had a relationship with that loved
being really loud while we had sex like
she was loud luck
22 and like we'd had the first time I
had sex with her she just starts
screaming I don't like shut the window
and cover her face people going shut the
[ __ ] the Russian upstairs was pounding
on the [ __ ] ceiling so he hated me
right and I knew I knew we were gonna
have a confrontation you know one of
these days you know one of these days
we're gonna run into each other so I ask
my instructor my karate instructor and I
told him the story and I told my big
ears I go what do you think I should do
you think I should come after him with
that overhand knife strike and he said
no
because this is what you should do you
should jump in the surcin you should
jump leap at him and punch both his ears
and it'll knock him out it'll [ __ ] up
his equilibrium he told me so much [ __ ]
are you sure he goes yes that's what you
do my [ __ ] that's what this guy [ __ ]
told me right I was gonna I would have
done that too
I would have done that so me and my
girlfriend were I was cranking Alice in
Chains never forget this and he started
jumping up on the on the floor pounding
the ceiling and you know old school
lights like for your for your room have
like a glass covering I don't know what
they call those but it's a glass
covering that you screw on when I shade
almost yeah it's like a shade it was a
big glass one and you had to screw it
off the change the lightbulb and then
you screw it back on and it's like it
looks kind of like a 70s feel and he was
pounding and that thing was rocking and
shaking and I ranked it even [ __ ]
louder I was pissed and he starts
jumping and the thing fell and broke
shattered and my girlfriend was putting
on her makeup like off to the side if he
would have landed on her head she could
have been seriously injured and it was a
little out dude and all of a sudden he
started chunk he stopped jumping and I
[ __ ] freaked out I got all the glass
and I put it in a dustpan and I went
upstairs nut pounded on his door and
threw all the glass like against his
door you know I was ready to throw throw
that jumping double finish punched to
the ears I was ready but he never came
out he was just silent and at all this
glass was sitting at the doorstep and
then I went back downstairs and I never
seen the guy ever again never heard a
peep from him dude he would have killed
me he would [ __ ] him humiliated me I was
gonna come after him what that [ __ ] I
said my instructor told me you don't
know once you knock on somebody's door
bro they might just shoot so you thank
God he was yeah yeah yeah he would have
[ __ ] me up this guy was huge he would
have [ __ ] me up so what do you think
about this [ __ ] column or [ __ ]
back this kind of work
guys I need bread man I'm so
no said about the corner virus the cloud
virus will you pay I think it's just
like Ebola and Zika and SARS every two
years there's this myth thing you know
and now I don't know man
I know there's different theories
there's one theory that says here's one
theory they're saying I'm because
apparently even though your phone says
5g they haven't rolled it out yet we
actually don't have 5g because it would
do have 5g might phone says 5g all the
time and it sucks
LTE crushes my 5g but but apparently I
could be wrong they're saying no no 5g
isn't even rolled out yet they're just
it's just saying it on your phone and
they're just advertising it but they're
not even using it yet when they do use
it it's gonna [ __ ] people up that's what
they're saying there's a conspiracy
theory the 5g it's gonna [ __ ] people up
like the waves the way it works is gonna
and the symptoms from 5g apparently are
like a radiation sickness symptoms like
flu symptoms I hear if you have
radiation sickness you it feels like you
have the flu apparently this is what I'm
hearing this is just the theory so
they're saying that one theory is that
Wuhan was the first city in China to
roll out 5g [ __ ] everybody up so they
blame it on the corona and they're
saying everyone's got karana when really
the five g's [ __ ] everybody up that's
just a conspiracy theory that's what I'm
reading who the [ __ ] knows I think I
think it's um another theory is it's
just they do this every couple of years
zika ebola stars to [ __ ] up elections
like obviously when it comes to trump
the fake russian hoax
that failed the fake rape claims failed
the fake impeachment failed all that
[ __ ] they're trying to frame him and
they're trying to [ __ ] destroy him
and it's all not working so the one
thing that Trump has done for us is he's
he's made our economy better than it's
been in 50 years or something like that
maybe that's a lie I don't know maybe
our economy sucks but I know my jujitsu
Association is stronger than ever and
that's a direct reflection of the
economy in my opinion
I think for me the economy's [ __ ] his
great so when people say dude the
economy is better than ever it's better
than it's been in 50 years I agree with
that because 10 planets blowing the [ __ ]
up so um the way like their last hope
there's a conspiracy the last hope is
okay let's do a some another zika ebola
operation where we scare everybody you
know apparently 20,000 to 50,000 people
a year died from the flu so there's
people dying all the time of the flu but
you never hear about it but if you take
this human coronavirus which is on the
back of Lysol if you look at the back of
a Lysol spray can it says it lists all
the viruses that it kills and it says
human coronavirus and uh so it's not
like it's new it's just like the
technical name for a kind of flu flu is
like there's a bunch of different
strains of flu and they have a bunch of
different names so one theory is this is
just a PSYOP to [ __ ] the economy up and
that it's work and if that's what it is
it's working because the stocks I don't
know anything about stocks but
apparently they tumbled in like the
economy is like getting taking a big hit
so that's a theory that it's all just an
operation just like Zika just like Ebola
you know and then one person died in the
United States and everybody's freaking
out
fifty thousand people a year die from
the flu so you gotta mean six people a
year die from like coconuts falling on
their head or something like that so one
person died in Washington and there's an
old lady I don't know I don't know what
to believe I have no idea another theory
is man there's there's a theory that I
don't know the people are saying we
can't even see viruses they're too small
to even see that we could see bacteria
but even through an electron microscope
apparently we can't see viruses so
that's why when you go to Google and you
put in virus it's gonna show you a bunch
of cgi pictures like it's never like an
actual picture of a virus in a cell it's
all CGI and when you do that you're like
[ __ ]
so people I don't know man I don't know
maybe like how do we know what the [ __ ]
is going on how do we know if we can't
see it so I've grown into a person that
I don't believe [ __ ] unless I could see
it
I could prove for myself otherwise you
don't have to believe in [ __ ] you could
just say I don't know I don't believe
you but I don't know I don't you don't
have to make a choice you know like oh
you have you either have to believe or
not like I don't know dude
you know after so many God - how many
lies does it take how many more bolas
you know how many more before you go
okay enough with the [ __ ] how many does
it take Creepo people forget about like
they're doing this every two years it's
always a new [ __ ] virus so they even
be nothing in like just it's something
to get us to talk about it because
that's all anyone's talking you talk
about it affects the economy that's what
they're saying that's a conspiracy
theory I don't know
I mean well know how much how much with
how many millions dollars has Corona
beer lost it's like 10 2 million $2
right more people die of Corona beer
than of the virus [ __ ] that's a fact
people getting drunk on that [ __ ] have
liver failure you know so I don't know
what to think about this [ __ ] they're
just so much all I know is that the left
is politicizing the [ __ ] out of it
they're blaming Donald Trump for the
[ __ ] coronavirus they're blaming them
they're blaming him the New York Times
put up a an article we should call this
the Trump virus if you get sick
you know who to blame so they're the
left is politicizing Nicias they're dead
why blame Trump cause he cut back on
whatever whatever you know it's like
okay it's like it's like how do you like
how could we blame Trump okay it's like
that it's like that let's how they're
coming up with the ideas how could we
blame Trump he let's just say he cut
funding to the CDC yes let's say that
did he
no but let's just say it so they put out
these reports that he cut funding to the
CDC and everyone's like oh my god what a
[ __ ] time to do this during the
coronavirus meanwhile he didn't cut [ __ ]
it's a completely lie there what we're
seeing now we're seeing that she always
he's always uh are suspicious of what
politicians say and what you hear on the
new drug you're people who say yeah I
don't believe that [ __ ] really but to
actually be able to see which like to
hear their lives and know their lives
that's new that's new we're actually
watching
and specifically knowing what the lies
are you know what I mean so they're
trying to blame Trump for the [ __ ]
virus for the one person dying in
Washington
let's blame Trump let's crash the
economy they want undercut an
apocalyptic event like the left cuz
Trump is busting them that's what's
going on right now Trump is busted but
but think about the impeachment the
whole impeachment think was about Trump
calling the President of the Ukraine and
asking him to look into the corruption
the Biden's are doing in Ukraine look at
these scams are running these tax scams
you know look into that [ __ ] and so
that's what the impeachment is about the
Pietschmann is about Trump is trying to
dig up dirt on his political rival
because he's running for president joe
biden look let's impeachment for trying
to dig up dirt meanwhile Biden is on
video sitting at the CFR the Council on
Foreign Relations sitting there bragging
bragging that he got a prosecutor fired
from the Ukraine was going after his
sons company in Ukraine so Joe Biden put
put his his son hunter Biden on the
board of burry smih an energy company
corrupt ass energy company that a
prosecutor was looking into and seizing
assets and stuff so there were all - Joe
coz Joe Biden was assigned to Ukraine
like that was his [ __ ] he was a vice
President Obama put him in charge of
Ukraine so burries was gone dude get
this [ __ ] prosecutor up my [ __ ] ass
right so Biden said okay of course cuz
his sons on the goddamn board of course
he's gonna get that so he's at the CFR
you can watch this on youtube you can
what there's a result he's bragging and
um he says he's telling all these
Illuminati guys saying I listen I told
the guy said listen you better fire that
prosecutor and listen I'm Melissa
leaving in six our limits we were living
in like six hours right yeah six hours I
told my go you're not gonna get your
billion dollars in aid unless you fire
the prosecutor and then he said you know
what he said he goes you don't have the
authority or not the president goes you
know and I said call Barak see what
happens and everyone's laughing
all these old muhfuckas a laughing
Council on Foreign Relations that's
Rockefellers [ __ ]
and these bragging
front of all these people these old
people who actually make all the laws
and I goes and guess what boom he was
fired and they're all laughing so it's
on video he was holding back a billion
dollars you know what they do is they
get a billion dollars in aid let's we
gotta help Ukraine they're getting
tortured does enema billion and
everybody they're tugging at everybody's
hearts yes it's I look Simon's bill sent
him a building
no one's getting a [ __ ] aid when we
send a billion dollars of aid to
countries no no money that's all going
on people's pockets you know what they
do they they would say maybe half of it
goes to whatever corrupt politicians and
the Ukraine are getting it and the other
half the deal is donate to our
foundations and that's how they they
launder it through their foundations as
donations so that's what that's how they
make the deals that's what Trump's
busting trumps busting all the shame the
only reason Joe Biden's son hunter Biden
was on the board he has no experience in
energy he didn't even show up he just on
a board and he gets eighty thousand
dollars a month from Ukraine tax money
so they're just trading tax money that's
all they're doing all this tax money
will send you a billion you send five
hundred back here and it's a lot of
these [ __ ] that's why they're
going after Trump because he's bust it's
not just Biden Biden's running for
president he's run for president for
protection because if you're running for
president they they like if he wasn't
running for president and Trump said
that he said hey listen look into all
this [ __ ] Biden is doing and he wasn't
running for president that's totally
legal they haven't opened up an
investigation and they'd crush him
Biden knew that this was going down so
that's why he's running as president
he's got protection you can't come after
me you're coming after Pluto you can't
attack a political rival we could
impeach you so that's why they're
impeachment never happened because when
it got down to the facts there was he
didn't nothing he did nothing wrong he
was looking into corruption so they're
willing to do that to the [ __ ]
president dude they're trying to frame
him and that's not the first time the
whole Russian collusion thing that's
what the investigation on how that
started that's what's going on right now
but as they were trying to as they were
investigating with Bob Mueller and all
that [ __ ] dude they were just trying to
frame him because he's busting everybody
he's not part of DC so they brought in
Trump because they knew he had but he
had big balls it's not his eye
they recruited truck what might you boy
Adam chef dick don't get Adam chef Jesus
that guy is hilarious that guy's so so
the call to call the impeachment call
was it was it was something like this it
was like hey look into the Biden's
they're doing some corrupt ass [ __ ]
right something like that right look
into the body so that they didn't think
Trump was gonna release the transcript
so they made up a call every shift was
gonna go in front of Congress and make
up this gangster call like like
something out of a [ __ ] like a Tony
Montana movie I told you I'm an idiot
but I'm like an old gangster movie right
Scarface or something and so before Adam
Schiff got up into Congress and just
read this [ __ ] call like a listen I
want you to dig up dirt on bitin my
political rival and I'm only gonna tell
you this seven times all right and you
don't call me and he's pretending like
he's reading it you don't call me I'll
call you and I want you to dig up a lot
of dirt on Biden meanwhile what he
didn't know is Trump released a
transcript before he made that's that
before he got up in Congress and
pretended he was reading the transcript
the transcripts totally for innocent
he's just like yeah look into Biden that
guy's a [ __ ] corrupt [ __ ]
yeah he's stealing our [ __ ] money you
know what I mean you look into that
[ __ ] that's what you're supposed
to do but he didn't make it look he ship
made up the phone call he [ __ ] made
it up he they didn't think Trump was
gonna release the transcript there's
there's a there's a movie going on a
series going on right now in DC you
follow that [ __ ] it's very very
entertainment I was totally the other
day out Sunday's podcast it feels like
I'm living in a dream as it is then I go
home and I watch world news too late if
I see these people and it's like a
[ __ ] joke to me it feels like a
[ __ ] joke yeah it was like how I felt
like when I was a kid and white kids
would tell me a show was funny and I
would watch him how
wouldn't laugh yeah and I thought it was
a joke you know like when I first
started doing boy I didn't get high of
the first six months I thought people
pull up my leg people had to talk was
the best feeling in the world I'd do
coke and not what happened nothing what
happened mr. six months nothing to
happen then I drank beer with it oh yeah
okay but before then I would drink I
would just do coke and it wouldn't do
nothing tell me the first six months I
did it yeah you know I never was a coke
guy at all no no but it makes sense most
most dudes who do coke drink - I don't
know booze and coke what my point was is
that I when I first started on coke I
thought it was a joke like people tell
me oh my god I did this coconut blew my
mind it wasn't getting me and I had it I
would do it nothing would happened and
I'd look around and people would be like
you know making faces and [ __ ]
talking endlessly and I'm like um that
[ __ ] don't happen to mate and then one
that I drank a case of beer with it no
oh [ __ ] but my point is that this is how
it feels right now when I watch what's
going down in Washington they're all
they're all yes it's like a [ __ ] joke
it's like a Telemundo novella it feels
like yeah they're all trying all of them
they're all the only reason the only
reason Fox News is getting the real [ __ ]
now because if like Darth Vader ran as a
Republican in one Fox News their job is
to blow up the Republicans so they'll
spin everything just like Santa's Bop
Fox's job is to support the Republican
no matter who it is so if it was [ __ ]
Adolf Hitler they would support him
right no matter what they're gonna they
were supporting it the bushes but it's
the only the only network that supports
the Republican before before Fox it was
all liberal CNN NBC ABC CBS whatever
they thought they're gonna shove it down
your [ __ ] throat so Fox came up as
you know one voice for the Republicans
there's a lot of corrupt Republicans all
the bushes are you kidding the bushes
were
the Dons george bush senior that guy was
he was number one he was right up there
with the Rockefellers you know certain
he was a Republican so my point is the
the fact that Trump ran as a Republican
he's to be a Democrat he has he has some
republican values some democratic values
but the plan was to clean up all this
corruption so that the plan was okay
you'll run as a Republican will have one
spot Fox they're finally gonna get like
real [ __ ] you know cuz again they would
lie they would spin everything to the
Republican side but the fact that Trump
is [ __ ] up bothers everybody should
be concerned about these tax scams
because they're taking our money I'm
concerned about my money
I give a lot of a lot of money to the
government and they're stealing this
[ __ ] they're stealing all our money and
Trump showing you how they're stealing
all our money with these trade deals
with China the reason why everyone's
getting the strength China because all
these [ __ ] trade deals that they've
been signing up for decades China
China's breaking in and we're getting
[ __ ] you see old clips of Donald Trump
when he's in the 80s and the 90s
there's all these clips he's like dude
who is making these deals we're getting
[ __ ] here cuz if I could
Oprah goes would you ever run for
president he's all young and [ __ ]
good-looking and he yeah he said nah nah
I love my life I love my life I love my
family I don't want to run for president
but I ever did it would be to fix these
trade dealer who's making these trade
deals were getting screwed left to right
our country's going down the toilet
someone needs to save this [ __ ] so he
was always talking about the [ __ ] that
he's doing now he he fixed the China
[ __ ] could you fix that it's not some
say that the coronavirus has something
to do with the something to do with
what's going on with the trade deal I
don't know but he fixed nap NAFTA was
terrible companies were companies were
moving out the last for the last few
decades they were all moving out because
it was too expensive to stay here
the country was going to [ __ ] now all
the companies are moving back for the
money because now it makes sense because
of the new trade deals you make more
money makes more sense to make
everything in the United States that's
the plan
the plan is to fix all of a [ __ ] they've
been doing for the last 40 years
the [ __ ] plan that's why they're
going after him Hollywood's going after
cuz they're all in bed together all of
them Hollywood the media everybody all
the big companies Time magazine New York
Times Washington Post
everybody is going they're all going
after him they're all going after them
you know what I mean and here we have
Fox they're like we want they're gonna
put a positive spin on everything
Republican but it just so happens that
they're getting the facts because the
facts are is Donald Trump was framed
frame that Russian collusion should they
framed him they set him up it was all a
setup and what's happening right now
today is it going back how it all
started and they're gone that's what
this coronavirus is a distraction that's
another reason that the coronavirus is
good for the Democrats because it's
slowing down the investigation on how
the whole rush inclusion thing started
and when you look into those facts [ __ ]
and the people involved and all the fake
warrants they got before the fake up
FISA warrants and all the time the lies
were getting like into the the details
the details of this case the case that a
framing Trump dude they framed Trump
they gave him Russia
that's the worst shooting him they went
after they gave the worship Russia rape
racism they gave him the worst [ __ ] and
nothing stuck I mean when Mexicans hate
Donald Trump because they they they
think he said Mexicans are all filthy
animals when he didn't say that he was
talking about gang members and the
criminals like ms-13 he was saying ms-13
the criminals are [ __ ] animals we're
gonna send them all back right so this
is CNN goes oh you know we could do with
this would you say did will do this
they'll say hey look what Donald Trump
said about Mexicans and they edit it and
goes they're filthy animals we're gonna
send him back so Mexicans [ __ ] heads
exploded
that's why Mexicans hate him because CNN
put out some [ __ ] he never said
Mexicans were filthy animals he said
gang members were filthy animals that's
what he was saying but no one no one
cares about that no one cares about that
that's how powerful the media the media
is super powerful
so bad last night I realized something I
was watching TV of my wife last my 16
minutes or whatever the [ __ ] and they
were talking about
there was a commercial and how they
tricked it they tricked the wording out
of it and they said sue here's what they
said be sure to watch CBS Tuesday to
pick your to see who gets nominated or
some to see who's your next president
the way they were lit was this is who's
gonna be your next present not to who's
gonna run for the election but you found
him saying to him so they were telling
you find out who was gonna be your
president it was like a mental wash type
[ __ ] thing I caught it I was like ooh
that didn't sound right right there so I
know the media is always [ __ ] yeah
that's why I don't watch [ __ ] dick
that's why yeah like I don't know I
gotta ask you guys a question
you both pretty smart dudes what the
[ __ ] am I am i liberal or my Republican
and my Democrat and my father right do I
hang to the left I don't even know what
this [ __ ] is yeah when I grew up the
right sounded like [ __ ] it was like oh
they're all about Family Values they're
all about Christianity they don't want
to they don't want me to have fun I want
to grow my [ __ ] hair and get drunk
get wasted [ __ ] chicks you know [ __ ]
being a Republican they're trying to
control us you can't control me I'm free
I'm a [ __ ] right you know it's speed
metal songs and but when you have a kid
and you grow up you realize [ __ ] I
thought they were trying to keep us from
that they weren't they want the kids to
be [ __ ] up they want that [ __ ] the
left wants that's what it is like a you
could be free to be with you know chase
your dreams go go to Hollywood be a rock
star and being they want that's how they
break families up it's an operation the
operation is break the [ __ ] family up
so it sounds like a great thing when
you're a kid being a liberal and free
and you know being able to do what you
want I don't want to go to church I
don't want to be a Christian [ __ ] Family
Values I don't have any kids but when
you have a kid you realize family values
are everything now you're not family
values you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] go
to church you know to me I don't go to
church but I believe in God I believe
I'm not asking because I just I don't go
to church my wife goes to Church of
mercy do I like it I don't like where
she goes but they have a good time makes
them feel good yeah I believe in the
value of family and I mean it's it's my
whole life right yeah that's a
Republican value like Republican is I
gun rights Second Amendment Family
Values
I'm down with Donna those two are very
important guns are very important to me
who like why would you give a [ __ ] how
many bullets I got a [ __ ] clip
why would you care if that was 15 or 9
why are you wasting your time on that
sounds like there's something else
you're thinking about inch by inch
they're trying to take all our [ __ ] you
can't do it all at once ain't stupid
you got to reduce the gun so why are you
worried about what the size of my
[ __ ] gun why are you worried about
that so you're trying they're trying to
disarm us to control us they can't
control us when we have guns they can't
we're gonna go to Texas from Missouri
[ __ ] go to Missouri and try to [ __ ]
around them up [ __ ] you see what
happened in Virginia they try to
implement some crazy gun control laws in
Virginia dude thousands of people showed
up with Fork and rifles and machine guns
and they went up to the like you ain't
taking this [ __ ] nada
there was no violence at all there was
no no no I Agent Provocateur is to start
[ __ ] they weren't gonna go there
everybody was dressed up like a [ __ ]
Navy SEAL go you ain't taking my [ __ ]
why they concerned like some kid shoots
up a [ __ ] school so it makes sense to
give up my guns does that make sense
it's so [ __ ] I should what do you
want a big gun for huh like why do you
heroin sighs my [ __ ] gun is fired a
bazooka wouldn't that doesn't mean I'm
more dangerous because I have a bazooka
if I had a ak-47 that doesn't make me
more dangerous that makes me more safe
that makes me more safe and follow a
bazooka I'd be [ __ ] people up I'd be
shooting I just I just want to keep my
family safe you know what I mean blowing
almost joints left and right
I see hummus on your menu yeah I would
just [ __ ] go there and see like the
Blues Brothers
yeah you think I'm kidding me what's up
flashbacks again now I'm I'm not
political I I specifically don't vote
because I think they're all liars and I
know I know how you feel about Trump but
you say you even said earlier like there
are a bunch of like shady Republicans so
let's say like Ted Cruz had one instead
of Trump or one of the other Republicans
had one do you think this would still be
happening I'd like Ted Cruz I like what
he's saying
oh no when you I never paid attention to
politics at all I just figured it was
all [ __ ] whether it was Republican
or Democrat I just figured everybody's
full of [ __ ] right that's that's a
that's what they want you to think
they're you're easier to control that
way cuz even though you don't watch the
news and you're not paying attention to
what's going on in Congress even though
you don't believe the mainstream media
that's what you couldn't believe anyways
because you're not watching the news at
all you don't believe in it but then you
hear a story from this guy at the gym
this guy or oh did you hear about Trump
though you're gonna believe that [ __ ]
anyways cuz that's all you know you
think you're not paying attention but
you are paying attention they would
rather have people not pay attention so
that but they had me I wasn't paying
attention
at all George Bush's I knew they were I
was in a paid attention to what was
going on in Congress but I was like
fascinated with looking into the bushes
and the Clintons and all that [ __ ] and
all the dirty [ __ ] they did like
conspiracy theory documentaries but not
I wasn't paying attention to what was
going on in Congress day
like daily just like shady [ __ ] that
they did in the past right so then
Trump's running for president in and I
didn't know anything about [ __ ] truck
I don't know I don't have I don't wasn't
a Trump fan at all I never watched his
TV show once all I knew he was a rich
you know arrogant pompous you know
loudmouth I don't know I don't know I
didn't and then I heard he's running for
president I thought that was funny
because I didn't know anything about ha
that crazy dudes running for president
ha ha ha what a trip and then you hear
from different people always [ __ ]
hilarious always crushing he's getting
you know and then Joe would say do that
Donald Trump he's you know he's he's
blowing up and my whoa that's [ __ ]
crazy of the TV reality show if I can do
it is blown up whatever I was thinking
that okay that's the sign of the end you
know what I mean it's a Donald Trump's
gonna he's gonna be you know he might be
president [ __ ] so I was thinking I was
not paying attention but I was paying
attention just randomly people would say
[ __ ] do you hear about Trump he's so
racist so then I thought Trump was
racist your Trump he's [ __ ] an
[ __ ] yeah trait Trump's an [ __ ]
how was that guy I wasn't paying
attention I was just going by what
people were hearing that we're watching
the news right so you think you're not
paying attention but you are indirectly
so you're gonna believe the mainstream
if you're not paying attention if you're
not paying attention you believe the
mainstream even though you don't know it
that's the way it goes
they love it they love that you're not
paying attention what do you think
football movies are and they know
everybody has an every week they got a
couple hours of free time and they go
damn this fill that up with as much [ __ ]
so they're not paying attention to
what's going on in Congress right so I
thought everyone was [ __ ] so then
what one thing I knew I knew like the
Clintons were bad people you know
whenever you know and there Hillary
Clinton's been involved in a lot of
crazy [ __ ] and allegedly so once I
started I started paying attention a
little bit and then I realized like [ __ ]
everyone's going after Trump now
everyone's talking [ __ ] on Trump I
thought maybe I go and then I would ask
friends go what did he say there was
races cuz I believe it ago I heard it
I'm like what was that racist [ __ ] so
then I started doing some research uncle
where's this racist [ __ ] that he hates
Mexicans and then when you find out when
you're a Mexican and you find out the
truth you want another truth find out he
didn't call Mexicans filthy animals
he called gang members filthy animals
but CNN and CNN BC they all push that
[ __ ]
so they have the power they're like the
big media so every by max again smoking
they want Trump dead dude I thought Guns
N'Roses Mexico City they had a trump
[ __ ] doll that they ripped apart they
want dead that's how powerful that [ __ ]
is how crazy is that
so then I started looking into my dude
look at all the people that I know
confirmed like me personally I come from
from my own research that were bad and
they're all going after Trump mm-hmm
there's something wrong here
so I just started listening to Trump
talk and I started listening to all his
speeches like no wonder he's blowing up
this [ __ ] not saying that's
same ol [ __ ] all these other politicians
for decades been saying this guy's
[ __ ] draw he's getting to the [ __ ]
real [ __ ] and then I started paying
attention just you know a little bit
more and then you got to think about
like this they want people to think that
everything is [ __ ] up and everything
is bad so that they don't look into it I
don't pay attention to it because
everything all [ __ ] up and that's how
I was but everybody's not [ __ ] up if
everybody was on the same team there
wouldn't be need for bribery they
wouldn't be need for suiciding people
are getting killed and [ __ ] when someone
gets killed because they're
investigating some certain people and
they get suicided and they make it look
like like an obvious not suicide it's a
suicide he [ __ ] took three bullets in
the back of the head suicide that's a
message shut the [ __ ] up
we own the corner the corner put suicide
and there's three bullets in the back of
his head that's a message just a
gangster message shut the [ __ ] up we all
coroner's standard you own the coroner's
no coroner's not owned maybe maybe a fee
or good but um when it comes to politics
when you start paying attention to the
actual people like the Senators and the
congressmen and all you start to realize
okay
who actually cares and who is full of
[ __ ] and the ones that are all full of
[ __ ] really quickly started separating
like oh [ __ ] oh these people that
they're all saying the same [ __ ] they're
all pushing the same [ __ ] all of them
they're same [ __ ] I already know five of
those [ __ ] are crooked as [ __ ]
so you can't you can't believe in and
then the other side you hear the other
side and there's good people out there
Jim Jordan Radcliffe Matt Gaetz Devin
Nunez trey Gowdy these people use when
you start paying attention like the this
is why people get suicided this is why
they get blackmailed
cuz there's there would be no reason to
blackmail anybody if everybody was on
the same team they're always good people
but you know what the bad people just
took over and put everybody put bad
people in in powerful spots important
spots where nothing could get done and
there's a bunch of good people in there
and it for decades trying to [ __ ]
they were just you know you know the bad
the bad people took over and right now
what's going on good people are pushing
back that's what this is all about the
good people got they needed a [ __ ]
lead singer with balls they needed a
lead singer with Boston to do a world
tour and who did they Trump was the guy
go trump is perfect Trump is perfect he
wants to change all these deals and go
after corruption anyways so Trump is not
a politician he hasn't been in politics
ever he's never been a politician he's
just a businessman and everybody knows
that there's mad mad corruption in
politics and there has been forever at
least decades at least since when George
Bush Senior took over that was it I mean
look at what we found out already look
at what as Americans what we found out
we found out that our own country
whoever I don't know who killed Kennedy
yep
we found that so far history has told us
over the years it's out there already
that the Mafia put the Kennedys in the
White House so he'd get Cuba back I was
the whole thing
mmm mafia was promised that if they put
the Kennedys in the White House they
take down [ __ ] Fidel they get Texas he
knows back and it would be business as
usual yeah okay we all know this is
American
they've told us already they didn't tell
us who killed Martin Luther King but
they already told this is the Kennedys
are pretty much as [ __ ] inside job
both of they killed the one and they
killed the [ __ ] brother
now you're 50 like me you already know
these things and then you see the ball
how it dropped on one of the things that
I think about it now and I watch it and
I get entertained but I gotta tell you
something while I watch this my insides
get mad because I was part of it and it
was part of almost killing me
wasn't my watch [ __ ] like Marcos what
episode are you up to four or five like
a [ __ ] snail once a week once or four
months Sunday night's me and the wife
that's our thing how even that works
it's so weird how even that worked out
yeah that our own country with Mexican
is the government Kiki Camarena and when
you find out all these truths and you go
I go wait a second you we you put in 70
tons of cocaine on one load 70 tons it
got to the point where they were flying
jet liners and filled with coke
everybody was in on it
mm-hmm then the Mexican government gave
zero [ __ ] zero [ __ ] the Mexican
government because our government was
doing it so welcome yeah what are they
gonna do it's they might as well jump in
on it so when you sit here and when you
watch what's going on today you
shouldn't be in shock exactly you
shouldn't be in trouble what what's it
gonna take what's happened the last 50
years in front of my [ __ ] eyes and
you're sitting there like ah that's why
when I watch this [ __ ] now it's like one
big telemundo novella every night last
night i was bored to pieces and i was
scrolling through me and my wife were
talking I put on that John Oliver's show
I was dying on laughter I mean I never
watched that show I just put it on for a
half hour the goof on the corner on
award diet but the kind of this disease
whatever the [ __ ] it is [ __ ] carnival
virus the caller will buy a virus and
[ __ ] Trump and the CDC and how Trump
walked out while the CDC guy was talking
his [ __ ]
when he gave it to Mike Benson by you
know you just see this whole thing
you're like what the [ __ ] this is like
one big novella yep it's it's super
entertaining I suggest no I got enough
going on in my world it's also just dick
and you're paying them they're taking
your money
oh no [ __ ] they're taking your money if
that doesn't bother your mom I stopped
taking my money you got a powerful
podcast man you could make you could
just talk about it I don't want to get
suicided I'm talk about what things I
learned things you learned this [ __ ]
thing this is what I was leading to look
at this thing that we all just watched
in front of our eyes we saw a guy going
to jail try to they tried to suicide
them a week Jeffrey Epstein they put him
in another prison sting and then they
moved them I watched the 60 Minutes I
read the thing and it's just [ __ ] or
[ __ ] like I've been in jail
you understand me I've been in jail I've
been in County I've been in County I've
been in [ __ ] state about was a member
when you got arrested for kidnapping
kidnappings automatically a federal
offense
yeah so they put you in federal hold me
I've been in every pen through the
[ __ ] system the only way you hang
yourself isn't when somebody kills you
yeah you know I'm saying yeah people
hang themselves they know they really do
but in today's society with the
technology you got now think about
you're gonna tell me there wasn't one
guard with a screen Joey Diaz has a
screen here I want no money cameras
didn't work when that happened yeah
think about it and think about the media
they're leaving it alone okay
so right cameras didn't work cameras
didn't work but there's still rounds
yeah just around whoa he got pulled out
a suicide watch that night why it's 72
[ __ ] out you know it's
stop that a guy like me really knows
that I go really really you're gonna
tell me some guy [ __ ] iced himself I'm
seeing [ __ ] at the county jail system
that would make the problem when I was
in County waiting against when I had
already been sentenced I was in the
county jail that a guard would tell me
every day
Diaz whatever you need and I thought he
was tricking me so I didn't [ __ ] with
him but I did send him to the
supermarket for me I would send him to
the supermarket me and this other guy
from New York Adams you know but I
wouldn't get alcohol or nothin like that
he would tell me write up for 25o wing
out green you know I thought I think all
that is I get potato chips frozen pizzas
you know like I live I can watch movies
at night til 11:00 if they have a snack
you know but I never I know that there
was people in there snorting coke at the
county jail level in Summit County
Colorado this is God's country
there was a guard there that everybody
know what small 25 a week you get free
food every night you get snacks every
night and you stay up watching TV all
night they put you in a cell with a TV
on that I signed up for the program he
would ask me do you want blow heroin
coke pills whatever you want you booze
whatever the [ __ ] you want so but I also
know that they checked on me counts even
and [ __ ] even a camp Georgia West my
counts were hourly yeah I don't think I
remember tripping yeah I don't think
anybody thinks he committed suicide I
was a trip her spiced remember doing
tripping I still remember doing acid in
prison so obvious that I was doing acid
no they did he
didn't care that's silly they couldn't
test you for in prison because they have
to do it through your spine so we could
eat acid that do your analysis that
didn't detect the acid over to hold him
speed an acid so we would pop an acid so
we would always have a life timer that
we were gonna see that guard every hour
yeah when he was there we are on the Oh
sometimes you cut back and come back
every half hour so don't [ __ ] tell me
no nobody
this is 1988 so our today's technology
the cameras were out that's you're
trying to sell me on you know how deep
Epstein s man oh my god no ask that and
look at the chickens disappeared dude
not only did he matter where's the check
no one nobody no one cares why you know
what why doesn't the media care you
don't think there's some kind of
connection there why wouldn't the media
be all over just laying maximum think
about that why wouldn't the media call
for her to get arrested you think why
hasn't she been brought in for
questioning her father her father's
Robert Maxwell he Jeff Epstein took over
for him he you look into that
[ __ ] Robert Maxwell that guy was
huge and his job was he worked for all
the intelligence agencies the main one
he worked in for Israeli intelligence
they ended up killing him allegedly but
while he was alive his job was to
blackmail politicians CEOs scientists
celebrities sports athletes as many
different powerful people as you can
like of year if your job is to blackmail
people like you would definitely like
ask who are the most important people to
blackmail like where blackboard is a
just blackmailing random people he was
picking people out of them on just we're
gonna blackmail you know specific people
with power who's who's a when you're on
that side of when you're on the dark
side a good person to blackmail would be
a politician for sure right
no one's gonna disagree with that
celebrities for sure
anybody with power with influence for
sure also scientists he was blackmailing
scientists why would you blackmail
scientists well what would be the
purpose there if you had to guess
to shut him up about some to say
whatever they need them to say about
this scientific experiment or that a
scientific experiment or these tests or
those tests for these drugs or for
whatever blackmailing scientist is huge
massive if you're in that dimension that
dark dimension right so that's what
Robert Maxwell did and that's what
Jeffrey Epstein is doing - Jeffrey
Epstein
he was balls deep in the scientific
community so do you think he's still
alive where he got murdered he could be
alive who Jeffrey Epps no he's dead as
disco Cena he's dead he just didn't
you've got his discard he's dead that's
too tough of a disappearing act the
family hired dr. bones to come in there
and do a separate autopsy he was a
national [ __ ] 60 minutes they said
that could be [ __ ] they're all there
they could he could be blackmailed
listen we got video tape of you with
some underage chicks go up there and say
go out there and do an occupation dr.
Boden comes legitimate that that's why
they don't think it'd be a good idea to
blackmail him no no he he won against
everything okay
he won against everything he said it
couldn't have been suicide but everybody
that's actually the mainstream the
mainstream is the Jeffrey Epson yeah
they murdered a by the ones okay he's so
deep no so deep that I wouldn't I
wouldn't be surprised that they just
faked his death like where's his body at
like who saw his body like a couple
people and they say it how hard is it to
pay them off how hard is it to blackmail
people that's what they do that's why
they blackmail people they're gonna
blackmail because you're gonna get him
front that [ __ ] Mike that's why
you're gonna get a friend of mine but I
don't know dead men don't talk I'm just
saying I don't know I don't know that
[ __ ] was in deeper than he could
for sure be dead for sure be bad
yeah you know dead men don't tell Motel
I just don't know I just don't why take
a chance
I don't know they they they ganya yeah
they ganya baby it was connected to a
lot a lot of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] and that
and you think about think about how the
media's has covered this they just they
want it to go away
no it just went away I don't they want
to go to it what about it what about
elected me to movement
how come what about Virginia Roberts
Regina Roberts their time I meet her
she's the one who's a constant going out
there making of it Harvey Weinstein was
the was the poster child for me too
yeah no but what I'm talking about kid I
gotta kill him the kid nobody ever have
seen [ __ ] with what about those kids
you know oh did you [ __ ] with a bunch of
you stay on cares about a [ __ ] about
them what people see it listen Americans
are gullible and stupid but there's
people like yourself and people like
myself that know we're not stupid
I'm not stupid I just I'm just trying to
raise a little girl it's right that I
could actually focus on this [ __ ] and
talk about it constantly and and school
people on it or whatever but I think I
always think that I think the way most
people think it's [ __ ] look at
everything that they thrown at us the
last I still remember there was a sparse
time of cocaine like in 86 when coke
changed
coke changed it went from tasting a
certain way in the late seventies to a
different way in the mid eighties it
changed did that have anything to do a
crack didn't know it had to do with
ether being smuggled into Colombia the
toughest thing wasn't smuggling the coke
into the United States it was smaller in
the ether into Colombia hmm
so Colombians had to stop coming up into
United States and processing the leaves
in the States because they ran out of
ether so they started processing it with
turpentine gasoline and they had a weird
effect can they grow coca leaves like in
greenhouses in the United States I don't
think so because of the altitude
see I don't know why I heard it was
something to do with the altitude but
the altitudes gotta be the same of a
point like Aspen Colorado but they can
make some kind of greenhouse reason and
I'd trust me
I think I'm not gonna day I know that I
have access to leaves if I want to buy
coca leaves somebody mentioned to me on
this side you put it in your mouth and
chew on it just put in your mouth
because a guy like Matt Hari he went
down and I go that was the main purpose
of you going down to his stupid was to
eat the leaves to see how that it's a
trip it's like the ceremony when you eat
the [ __ ] leaves and chew on them and
swallow them it goes into your system
that's what makes those farmers farm all
day they're going to like a [ __ ] haze
it's like my boy and Joe caught on to
women when Joe read the paragraph of
what happens to you when you eat an
edible course in your liver and it
becomes CTE one he went into it he read
it over and over again
he had it down doesn't it become CTE one
that highly polite he read it and
studied it to the T he
right now will call him to say what you
do what does edibles do to you they say
the same thing and they go and deliver
and it becomes a car nib annoying and it
does but that's Jeff Koch from the
eighties it turned and that was when the
government got involved
once the our government said whoa these
[ __ ] making some serious money
we need some of that paper and that's
when they jumped on Noriega yeah they
needed money behind black ops money that
was running guns running drugs through
Arkansas while Bill Clinton was the
governor to go there yeah that's why he
became president they say you let us use
your state as a drop-off point for all
this coke I mean they even put it in
that movie american-made Barry seal he
was the CIA pilot there's books written
on him he was dumping her off and mean
Arkansas while Bill Clinton was the
governor and George Bush scene
was the president and then guess who
became the next president George Bush
Bill Clinton Bill Clinton what about the
head hey you think he cook tomorrow it
was like a favor what about the scene
when he's an American me Tom Cruise is
making so much money his Barry seal and
they finally arrest him and they take
him down to the police station and he's
like you know what man you guys never
drive Cadillac I'm gonna buy each and
every one of youse a Cadillac and
they're like are you trying to bribe us
and he goes no I'm not trying to bribe
you he goes I'm just trying to give you
a little something for your efforts
today I'll tell you why cuz in about
five minutes
that little District Attorney lady's
gonna come out of her office and she's
gonna tell all you boys to go home and
I'm gonna walk on out that door and
they're like sure
cos and she comes out closer to the
prosecutor so whispers in his ear be how
I don't go and they're like what why he
goes I told you fellas you should have
took the Cadillac that's just like he
was connected all the way through he was
working for that case one of us shut him
down and they threw everything away and
they [ __ ] then a few remember the
nephew and each other when he dropped a
nephew off that's what they were pipe
bomb and people that's what they were
bombing people and they bombed that guy
from Aspen Colorado - his name was
Stephen Grabow he was about to testify
against him and they put a car bomb in
his car that's what the Colombians are
doing then and supposedly he was the
white guy from cocaine Cowboys he later
on wrote a book called American
desperado and he wrote all the bombings
he was paid to do for the cartel very
interesting [ __ ] allegedly Epstein has
been involved in high-level [ __ ] for a
long time he was he had a job and
iran-contra scandal like he was all up
in it back then apparently they found
like his helicopter had plates on it
that were from the US government so I
don't know what that means exactly but
he was connected man he was he had he
was doing something for multiple
governments for a very long time
he wasn't just videotaping old
politicians having sex with minors he
was doing a lot of other [ __ ] so it
wouldn't handy when you came in you were
saying how the history books say Oh
everywhere every country says oh we're
the best
is there somewhere we could move now
like is there a country somewhere that
isn't doing all this [ __ ] like or is
every country doing all this stuff I
don't know I don't know I don't know
where you'd run to but I thought about
that if I had to leave like [ __ ]
Iceland maybe you know yeah maybe I
don't know I don't know I really don't
know it's the price I don't know where
to run to but you know all I care about
is my family my wife my son my tax money
like where it's going that's why I care
now it's like that's my [ __ ]
money and eat my [ __ ] are still on
that I want to pay attention I want to
know what the [ __ ] going on that's my
money and on top of all that it's so
entertaining following what's going on
cuz it is like a movie we're [ __ ]
living it and it affects our lives
directly you know gun control affects
our lives directly our taxes that
affects our it's like watching your
favorite series every day there's a new
episode every day there's a new episode
can you imagine of Game of Thrones every
[ __ ] day Sopranos every [ __ ] is it
is it's gone there's one going on right
now and you could pay attention to it
and learn about all the characters
because it would take you a long time to
learn all the characters names in game
Game of Thrones like if someone just got
into Game of Thrones now it could be
until season two or three before they
got everyone's names that first episode
they're not gonna remember anybody's
names second episode they're not they're
barely putting it together second
episode you know that's how DC is -
there's a lot of good guys and a lot of
bad guys and you got it takes a while to
keep track of them and remember their
names put their faces to names and
realize who that the good guys are the
bad guys are now if Trump is a big sign
up
this is all the big sigh and you know it
could be because it you know um
conspiracy theorists are basically
saying one thing there psyops going on
all over all over the [ __ ] place
everything's a PSYOP everything's
there's fake [ __ ] going on everywhere
now
Trump is not a politician he comes in
he's busted out their scams
they're attacking him it appears that
he's a good guy it appears that he is
listen to what he's saying actually
listen to him it appears that he has a
real heart it appears that it cares
about his family his sons and his
daughters it appears that way
it appears that like the left want him
gone they're trying to ruin it appears
that they're framing him all that but
you know if it turns out that it was all
an act
and Trump and Hillary really like each
other and they're just playing a role
that's a PSYOP so they got me
[ __ ] you got me you got me it
doesn't mean that every that it doesn't
mean that I was wrong about the
government it means I was [ __ ] right
again they just tricked me but I don't
think it's a trick I think this is real
I think the hate between the left and
Donald Trump is real I think they're
really trying to destroy him I think
they tried to gave him Russia they gave
him you know [ __ ] they had a girl
there yeah you know big it like with
Kavanagh like that judge that he put in
to the Supreme Court they throw out rape
and [ __ ] they just said dad this chick
said you raped her you know they don't
give a [ __ ] they're gonna throw rape at
you just like make [ __ ] up they don't
care there's making [ __ ] up the girl
that they brought out that said uh Trump
raped me like 20 years ago they got her
on CNN and Anderson Cooper's Oh tell me
all about it Trump's going down tell me
how what happened you know start from
the beginning and then halfway through
the story they thought they had they
thought they had Trump she starts going
Looney live on CNN she goes I think she
said something like a women kind of get
turned on by rape they have a rape
fantasies and Anderson Cooper goes oh
what and she starts saying crazy [ __ ]
like that they were and then they got
cut cut cut boom and then you never
heard from that girl again she was gone
they're if they're willing to frame the
president dude a scary [ __ ] a scary [ __ ]
man so I'm very entertained by it all
you know they got me if they have to
stop and they got me and Trump's really
some Zionist you know like people are
saying I'm if that's true you know cuz I
don't believe anything a hundred percent
then they got me and then it just proves
that I was right
there's psyops going on all over them
because that's an elaborate SIOP cuz
that's a PSYOP oh that's so good that's
a good one when they got it put if Q is
a PSYOP because Q is an information
dissemination program so Trump knew that
the media is gonna [ __ ] bury him so
he needed a way to communicate with
people that really just want truth they
want their family they want their guns
they want freedom of speech they're true
Americans that aren't corrupt they just
want the best for their families so
that's what that's what Patriots are
Patriots are we care about our country
first our family our kids family unit
you know God is important you know got
to do the right thing Family Values so Q
is a way that Trump is communicating
with every all the Patriots that's what
Q is has been going on for three years
people thought it was fake the the
mainstream so afraid of the fact that
the Trump administration is
communicating and without the media
because if you all you got was a from
Trump was what the media was giving you
[ __ ] of course you think he's racist of
course you think he's [ __ ] insane
because they're taking everything out of
context and putting everything together
make it a little crazy make it only look
like he's gonna [ __ ] destroy the
world meanwhile if you're paying
attention he's actually trying to he's
not a politician so we all know
politician but the politics have been
corrupt for decades the policies been in
politics for decades Schumer Nadler all
of them and Pelosi got millions and
millions of dollars Maxine Waters been
in politics forever we all know politics
is corrupt Donald Trump is not a
politician so when he comes in call how
could you do defend Donald Trump didn't
you say government is corrupt yeah yes
he's not part of the government he's
brand [ __ ] new he's been in three
years and guess what he turned around
the economy
you know he's fixing these trade deals
companies are moving back to them I
don't I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
alone I know you I go I see cranes yeah
and I know every comedy club is packed
yeah economy's booming I know that
people are paying 300 I'll go see Guns
and Roses yeah I know they're gonna pay
500 to see Metallica that Metallica Van
Halen on Van Halen the other Motley Crue
and yeah poison bigger than that you
know it's bigger than average it's is
bigger than ever you know I mean I feel
bad if this coronavirus is a hoax or
whatever because guns and roses a lot of
people have canceled their Asian legs of
their tours like they've just can't stop
even the Korean boy band canceled them
you know so baby metal there's a bunch
of little shrine and Japanese chicks and
[ __ ] Disneyland is closed you know
you know this fears this could go either
way so yeah I think it's just another I
hope we'd just go to Zika you know I
wanna go to New York I'm [ __ ]
concerned thousands and thousands of
people died of the flu every year and
one has died of coronavirus so far even
if even if they say oh the it's up to
450 people have died from Corona they
can make that sound [ __ ] crazy
450 but it's nothing when you look at
how many people died of the flu symptoms
people dying all over the place the flu
so you can make 500 sound crazy even
sound crazy totally a [ __ ] dog in the
back and they've seen the [ __ ] like I
say to you all the time
Chinese people could solve a Rubik's
Cube but they'll [ __ ] either dog who
does that [ __ ] who looks at the dog
that's the best taste in [ __ ] dish
I'm gonna have today who's gonna kill a
[ __ ] dog and eat it they ate a dog
you know Bruce Lee Anil is the Chinese
connection remember in the cemetery
remember when he runs away they're
looking from that the Japs are looking
for Bruce Lee and he goes to the
cemetery and the chick comes and she
stalks him in Chinese connection
what is he eating a [ __ ] lizard okay
you ever go to Chinatown you shoot a
[ __ ] thats hanging off the [ __ ] dings
yeah you see the things they eat I went
if this country [ __ ] fish eyes and
[ __ ] like that
eventually something bad is gonna
[ __ ] happen so this all started with
a [ __ ] cat eating like a [ __ ] bat
like you know like that's what they say
that's what happened and this
[ __ ] Jonny Wu says I'm gonna
move from [ __ ] cats today so he calls
little Jonny Wu he stabs her you know
she's got capped leather than a [ __ ]
mouth you know those Japs don't eat the
teeth and though he dies for their
hard-on they'll try anything right the
wind don't they cut them wasn't a
thousand shark swimming with no fins
because they cut the fin off they eat
the fin juice so the dick gets hard Japs
and Asians whatever that we eat anything
the [ __ ] is to make their dick hard
they'll try it one of them dolphins
dolphins no eat anything but how about
how about balls there's a restaurant in
China you're going in order like [ __ ]
spider balls walk like a Cavs balls to
give you to get some something's balls
oh I think you could either human balls
in China like a mule on the back you
know look cook a week anyway stab
marinate the balls how about an India
cows are revered they're like sacred
animals and what do you think they think
about us like we that's all we eat is
cows let me tell you something I also
know a preschool teacher and she had
preschool little Hindu kids
she said all they ate was hard-boiled
eggs and some pickle juice and their
shits were the worst and the whole
[ __ ] school at the girls weighed 30
pounds of beer they take a [ __ ] they
thought it's not like a circus [ __ ]
[ __ ] or whatever they're some countries
out there that they have that use
chickens as pets and they love chickens
and they find out Americans [ __ ] eat
chickens and we have chicken
slaughterhouses and then you go to
Mexico eat chickens your name
you kill that [ __ ] chicken [ __ ]
Kentucky Fried Chicken beat no poyo logo
that would be bro when I was a kid I
used to eat all the chickens in the
Santeria things those chicken for fresh
Jack yeah we can you do a Santeria
[ __ ] ceremony that's either yeah yeah
you could eat it oh my god but they
would never like a rooster they had all
the birds that you don't want to eat
pigeon then what the [ __ ] one see the
pigeon that's a bat a pigeon is a bat
without aids that's all the [ __ ]
pigeon is no idea oh whatever this is
the last podcast Oh I don't give a [ __ ]
okay what are you gonna do throw me in
jail why is that unless you spoiling and
getting the roof of a virus
I want to thank any Bravo
and I want to take the fly and you with
most importantly I want to thank you
savages for always listening to the
church and supportiveness real quick the
church what's happening now is sponsored
by zip recruiter listen hiring used to
be hard multiple job sites stacks of
resumes confusion review process
background checks you got to meet people
today hiring is easy and you only have
one place to go to get it done and
that's zip recruited coms last Church
zip recruiter sends your jobs over a
thousand of web's leading job sites but
they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job you
could even add screening questions to
their job listing so they can filter
candidates and focus on the best ones
listen stop it
whether you have a small business you
got 800 employees you and I both know
zipper you know at the time time is
money you gotta go sit with people meet
them for coffee talk them smell bad
breath forget that
zip recruiters the way to go zipper code
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day the first day one day and right now
try zip recruiter for free gratis the
church
we can go to zipper cooler calm slash
shirts that zipper cool.com slash shirt
si-hu rth zipper kulikov slash church
the smallest way tire is with zip
recruiter just what I'm talking don't
forget next Thursday the 12th of March I
will be at levity live at night one show
only eight o'clock in and Island a
Thursday night no second show do what
you got to do March 27 I'm at Arlington
theatre and Santa Barbara one show do
what you got to do and beside that way
you had this month March 19th in
Pasadena the Ice House Huntington Beach
Sam Tripoli we say our temperament
me and Sam Triple E Huntington Beach
April 11th at the rec room were Chicago
May 9th at the den theater also Spokane
and Tacoma May 1st and May 2nd look at
you go right up to Washington to get
that card Nokomis awesome we did it you
know we're doing we're doing day shows
on Saturdays do - and they're [ __ ]
fun and we've been selling them out it's
crazy to Como that we're going back and
doing another 420 420 at the Comedy
Store
the at night or during the day at night
okay the clock what date is that
following Monday okay that place on two
of them go up on stage it's hopefully
there's no at this the only weight gets
on that stage - what a milligrams a die
everybody will get no lis professionals
you're the up and you're doing a 420
show in Tacoma
that's a May 1st and then Spokane oh no
no no May 2nd that's a Saturday May 2nd
in Tacoma at the Tacoma comedy club
Spokane is that Friday mmm may Allah may
burst may 1st you're doing some good
things brother thank you
digits is better than ever man we're
just growin time somebody told me they'd
move somewhere in Jersey that's cool
they have a new 10th planet in Jersey
Newton New Jersey Newton um what else
two of them Woodbridge Woodbridge we
have Allentown now at Sylvania Bethlehem
has been a force alpha whether they're
the ones you know control in that area
it's amazing we got combat jujitsu
worlds coming up not this Sunday coming
up what is it March 8th Sunday at the
Orpheum Theater downtown LA 5:00 p.m.
Pacific Standard Time its on UFC fight
pass combat jujitsu world's gonna be
insane man it's gonna be [ __ ] crazy
and we got the UFC on Saturday oh yeah
companion or not just working it yeah
just work great to see you great to see
you man back to your family do not
forget next mate March 12th Nyack and
March 27th the Arlington Theatre in
Santa Barbara
I'll see you [ __ ] next week
have a great weekend
stay black and be careful of [ __ ]
you